DDP what's going on pal how you doing
sit down I accept my alarm clock as I've
been running all week and I set my alarm
clock for 8:45 p.m. you just woke up I
woke up I woke up like eight forty nine
I was like why do you go off I'm staying
over the Omni so is a quick jolt over it
okay you do you panic when you sleep
during alarm uh yeah absolutely because
first of all you know I will night
finally I don't sleep well anyway I'm up
and down because my mind won't shut off
got too many things going on yeah can
you drink caffeine late in the day um
you know that doesn't really affect me
caffeine is hot Jim is convinced tell me
this DP you know a lot about the body
sure and and I mean part of of DDP yoga
is about nutrition you know Jim thinks
these caffeine addiction because when he
doesn't drink coffee gives him headaches
but oh wait wait that's but at the same
time even interrupt him when he's siding
with meadow God God was at the same time
he also thinks that he's so sensitive to
caffeine that if he drinks one cup of
coffee at 3 o'clock in the afternoon he
won't be able to keep me out Mike hit me
up yeah I I would find that harder if
you go to sleep it six o'clock at night
and you guys gonna really show yourself
I don't know what time you go to bed but
you know when it comes down one wouldn't
what my buddy Marlon stop drinking
coffee he had ten days of extreme
headache yeah by the 10th one he was
like dude what are these headaches gonna
stockers I don't know how much coffee be
drank you know it's it's an addiction
just like anything else yeah yeah yeah
the I don't know if it would have
actually kept me up it may or may not
have any chance probably not it's your
little brain you little brain going
crazy going like I think it's gonna keep
me up I think he's gonna keep you up I
think he and that's it might have but I
wound up getting to sleep on time so I
wound up doing the right move JTP that
he stays up all night because he's
productive he's got a hundred different
operations going on all at the same time
yeah well like for me I don't want to
you know I don't want to start any
dialogue in my head if I start to wake
up because then I'll go right to that
right instead of going back to sleep
right right right but under now don't
you have to sleep like I have to right
isn't that isn't that part of nutrition
and all that and living
gotta sleep oh thank you thank you for
bringing that up to there's times like
over this loop I've been really crazy
busy because I went to go see my sister
because they were filming my sister my
mom my wife and my best friend Gary
Rossi they were filming her and my buddy
at my my sister's house in a matter of
fact my buddy Paul Smith like my
brother-in-law is actually I'm sure
listening to the show right now
these big fans of you guys but we went
there because WWE came in and they're
doing my documentary part of the triple
DVD series that'll be out in March
oh wow it was really cool cuz it's
pretty amazing yeah everyone always says
when they gonna do a DVD series on you
when they're ready yeah you know when it
happens you know so for me going back
home down Point Pleasant New Jersey and
going to the park you know Lawrence to
play basketball because that's where I
learned work ethic yeah you know all the
little things that the the biography
part is going to be called their choice
of this positively living and the
unpretty positive guy did a book called
positively page perfect another thing
I'm up here for today I got a UH there's
two big publishers I think once called
Rodale Rodale or some like that and the
other ones Simon and Schuster I got
meetings of both of them about my
inspirational book on your life that
I've been working on for about last six
months in between everything else do you
anybody are writing it with are you just
doing yourself um all the perhaps trip
dude I grew up with a DD in dyslexia I
was reading at a third grade level to
age of 30 so I will definitely have
something I you know with especially
part of this structure and everything
well [ __ ] you up more the ATD than just
likes you um well I started to learn how
to read at 30 so he started to read 30
31 actually that's why I made a decision
I mean I was reading a third grade level
on my kitten and it was yo I just I
don't know what a DD or dyslexia was no
one knew what that was really stupid in
school but yeah that's you know not me
but they didn't call me that but they
thought we were right you know and I
knew I was really smart but at the same
time that reading thing didn't work for
me so I like cheat my way through school
like I graduated like two hundred and
ninety-ninth out of two hundred and
ninety-nine but at 31 I made a decision
to start to learn how to read and what I
did was I am if you don't change your
circumstance when you're gonna do DDP
yoga or you're gonna do it any fitness
program if you don't change your
circumstance the way you live in some
way you might start and go for a couple
days maybe a couple weeks but then yes
sort of life gets in the way right and
for me it's the same thing about reading
and I always say just don't think it ink
it and I put read today everywhere all
over my house and I said it off myself I
was going to read it well so you
literally have it written all over the
but we're seeing it but if you're seeing
it backwards it's today dear and that's
how the journey started I set a goal
that I was going to read a book from
cover to cover and I finally did that
for first time ever you know and when
did you do that you did that in your 30s
for the first time 31 what book was it
it was a Lee Iacocca's autobiography
interesting one to pick that's a pretty
pretty big undertaking well think about
who that guy was
I mean he well he should've been up he
was they were trying to get him to be
the president and then when they got
that he said no I'm not gonna do I'm not
gonna do what you tell me to do I'm
gonna do what I want to do so since
reading came like late and you're like
you actually like value it oh yeah you
don't waste your time with any of the
Harry Potter [ __ ] do you know it's
ridiculous it's a stupid well you know
to me but my my nieces they read that
stuff right little kids yeah yeah what
uh
Adrienne likes it he's these he's in his
20s he's a young man and he's reading
Harry Potter still yeah you know some of
the stuff I read I always say it's stuff
that's gonna help me that's what I read
stuff that's good yeah I earn me or
motivate me let me ask you when you got
uh dyslexia and you're reading a book
what is one of the tricks to stop you
from like [ __ ] up the words like what
do you have to do in your reading like
okay I got us how do you make yourself
get through a page well I went to the
eros Learning Center in at 47 years old
in Culver City California and I had a 85
year old woman your name was rose and
they do all these different things -
like procure help you program your brain
like I'll give example they might put
four cards and they might have like
splotch marks on them
and you look at them then they turn them
over shift them all up and then now put
them back in that order it was things
like little tricks that they did like
that but for reading it's just about
repetition you know and I practice
reading out loud all the time because
there's a point so you saw the induction
of jake the snake' roberts to you yeah
no of course
I'd written what I wanted to say because
I wanted to have it in blocks but you
would never know it because I made it
like a like a a prompter and right
before right two hours before without
Triple H what's up to me he goes Adia I
love what you're what you got going
there you go spent maybe is a little bit
too dark over here you know maybe you'll
give them a light over there so two
hours before about to go out I had to
change stuff and for you that might as
well be 30 seconds before you go out
because you've been practicing the last
thing you need to do is get in front of
an arena full of wrestling fans and be
the guy who can't read exactly yes I've
been that kid right that kid all my life
just like doing a book report but in
front of 15,000 people right and uh but
I just I just hit it really hard and
before I go out there before you go in
the ring like you guys today don't even
think about this today but when you
first started in radio you would nervous
as out yeah when you first started but
you were going oh god oppa don't [ __ ] up
up I don't [ __ ] up I don't [ __ ] up your
own I'm gonna nail this this could be
great I'm gonna show I'm prepared you've
got to have yourself fill yourself with
positive energy positive conversation I
always talk about you know the story we
tell ourselves the biggest reason I
could help turn Jake and Scott around
would you take the snake and Scott Hall
yeah okay the resurrection Jake the
snake by the way second highest rated
sports talk on Netflix really number one
highest rated biopic really yes that's a
lot of sports documentaries on Netflix
all the third 4:30 yeah what great
matter of fact the guys from 30 for 30
right now uh-huh
we're talking because they saw the movie
and I have this idea for a show
and that we just reached out and they
pulled me in I met with a couple
different production companies but that
one those guys are so authentic yeah now
we're going through the contracts and I
hope we come to a yeah we all are happy
was it a wrestling thing no not at all
it's more about um you know it's I
wouldn't say it's an addiction house or
anything like that to me I explained to
them like a lot of production companies
can you do this in eight weeks can you
do this at 12 weeks um no it's like a
year right now to really make an impact
but the real impact that I teach and I'm
a big Tony Robbins fan I have been for
30 years because I couldn't read Tony's
books but I could listen to his little
cassette tapes right you know 32 years
ago and they really helped guide me in a
lot of different places and one of the
things that I've always said and I just
heard him say at a conference about two
years ago one year ago was about the
story you tell yourself like that
instant a little dialog going on in your
head before Jake the snake Roberts or
Razor Ramon walk through that curtain
they weren't going oh my god I hope I
don't blow this open a [ __ ] this up I
don't suck tonight they were thinking
I'm the king of the world I'm going out
there I must steal the show this is
going to blow the roof off I said why
can't you say that to yourself when
you're out of the ring why can't you
supply it to literally everything you
have everything the only scary thing
about that and this is where I've always
given myself negative messages before I
go onstage is because if like for me if
I give myself message this is gonna be
[ __ ] amazing and then the first joke
bombs I'm like oh no negative talk as a
comedian can work for you yeah yeah
that's the only place you make it work
it might be the only place it worked
right yeah the positive talk would be
like I'm gonna make this [ __ ] work
and even if it doesn't work I'll still
be able to make it work that's what you
say Jim whatever positivity not like oh
this mic sec I thought I probably
shouldn't vocalize that to the or that's
why I've been going wrong I've been
going all look this is probably not
gonna be very good
I guarantee you get a huge laugh out of
that
so were you like a late like when you're
when you're a young guy in your teens
and twenties are you still motivated to
do things because it seems like
everything a lot in your life anyway
started late whether it's you know
reading your 30s or wrestling didn't
start until like even after that um what
are you doing in your teens and 20s well
you know you you put everything into
sports yeah at least I did there's you
know ain't gonna work with the studies
so uh at UH at 12 years old I was pretty
pretty damn good football player and a
position um defensive end and center
play both ways your Pop Warner you know
but you know we had a pretty good group
of guys at that time and I mean to me I
don't doubt in my mind I was gonna play
defensive end for New York Giants I mean
that's my mind said I'm 12
right and I played hockey and I I made
this team that was 14 and 15 year olds I
was 12 that next day I walked out in
front of a car hit my right knee my face
my face bounced off the hood and I flew
42 feet from pointed him back Wow no
more football no more hockey I begged my
mom to take me to see dr. Nicholas up
here he was the New York Jets doctor at
the time he had worked on Willis Reed
and he worked on Joe Namath so you're
like an obsessive fan that knew all that
stuff well right you know I I guess I
guess I must have because yes how it
found him and I begged my mom you know
she's a single mom you know and living
with my grandmother I begged her to take
me to see him cuz he could fix my knee
you know he told me you're never gonna
be Joe Namath you're never gonna be
Willis Reed he literally said that to me
he said yes you need your knees pretty
screwed up he's like you know I can't
really do anything with it where it's at
right now and you know you just work on
your studies they try to tell that to
boobie miles and he [ __ ] freaked out
on the doctor who's goofy mile you ever
seen Friday Night Lights all right yeah
yeah yeah yeah I watch that yesterday oh
okay it would not just that movie but
that series the series is great
unbelievable I named my name my dog Lyla
Garrity uh
as I did she from that series she is
she's smokin she is yeah yeah ridiculous
she's a blonde on it but so you get to
the doctor and he's like you're not
gonna play football dude all right um I
was pretty depressed I call that
emotional gravity do you think you were
[ __ ] up as he said it was he just
trying to guide a young guy into his
studies well you know I don't think he's
trying to guide me in my studies you
know I guess he didn't think I was going
to be a Diamond Dallas Page right right
like it was the first time that someone
told me what I couldn't do now like you
know what [ __ ] you if I can't do that
I'll do something else right and and I
always looked up it it for my whole
beginning of my youth that in my career
I was trying to prove everybody wrong
today I try to prove myself right again
the message you said yourself you know
and oh I see so like because proving
yourself wrong is coming from that
negative perspective on things right as
because you now you're listening to the
people that are like me are gonna maybe
be a manager in wrestling but you're too
old you can't start now bah bah bah
instead of focusing on that you're
focusing on like no no I think I can so
I just focus on this when I walk into
the studio every morning I give the
message of let's think of what we can do
instead of what people tell us we can't
do you do yes I watch how you handled
Nancy Grace you were very graceful yeah
you really were you were classy unlace
like you saw with you she was so nice to
me
right before the camera went on like I
was like oh this is gonna be awesome
right cuz she was so nice I took a
picture I had to die we cut her
everything but I know before the show
before the show what do you think of her
after the show I wanted to kill her
yeah when I choked her out you know my
wife is said to be like like she shake
her head like no cuz I was so pissed
before into the interview did you
realize oh oh pretty quick oh she was
this sterile everything right but she
just started talking she started talking
about the steroid scandals and blah blah
blah like wait a minute that was 25
years ago
right DDP was on the show where she was
talking about the Ultimate Warrior's
death that's what we confronted her on
on the show you did I didn't know any of
this stuff Sam knew all of it and she
brought up like she's like listing the
wrestlers that have died
and she puts like Owen Hart who died you
know in in the ring and and like you
know all guys who died of gunshot wounds
and just stuff that had nothing to do
lumping it all in with that exactly and
think about his kids and wife at that
time right what the like I wonder like
because they are the nicest people and
for warrior to come back you know and I
was just so happy that everything was
fixed beforehand that happened so he
could be put in the spot that he
deserved to be in right and you know I
thought we were gonna talk about you
know the time like imagine is I'm its
WrestleMania sex I'm the driver
for the hockey talk man in a pink
Cadillac like the car my pink Cadillac
convertible got the gig not me so that's
how you got the gig as the driver
because you had a pink car example get a
picket look the bushwhackers good buddy
mind he came by my club and he saw the
new sort of you know the convertible
he's like dude I think I get you at
mania I'm like seriously I just want to
go right now and I'm already Diamond
Dallas Page but for this day I would be
diamond dollz chauffeur what kind of
Club was it um because I was a dance
club oh it's good Club no no I do like
dancing Oh party if I were growing up in
the strip club business I would have
been so [ __ ] so good I'm like sad and
glad at the same time uh-huh but um I
met that at that mania Hogan and warrior
are the main event right so now let's go
eight ten years later do the eight years
later eight years later and now I'm the
main event with Goldberg and I'm sharing
it with warrior and Hogan why with WCW
so when warrior comes in like he calls
for you know he has someone get me in
Goldberg and we go to see him and he was
so cool you're so gracious because I
want you guys to know you're the reason
why I'm doing this I see you guys have
it so much fun I wanted to be part of
the fun again wow that was that's what I
want to say yeah great and warriors the
guy who at the time was bitter about the
business so the fact that he saw that it
was fun again yes he's like I want to go
back and have a good
I'm like he wanted he liked it and he yo
cuz he yo he loved the growing up in the
whole deal but you know it that that we
were a part of helping him want to do
that like that's what I want to talk
about is that way they brought you in
saying that you were gonna talk about
how they they always yo they tell you
what they did you assume because of what
happened they're gonna have some
memories of the word that I didn't
really think soon as she started I
thought oh my god dude you're on TV with
Nancy Grace now like be killer yeah she
can be a sweetheart you've seen her be
that too right I thought that was one of
these things especially when she was a
fan well they say she's a pig in sheep's
clothing a lot of wool yeah I mean look
she went on like the view and all the
shows after she did our show and acted
like this sweet lady was the victim of
everything like she was just bombarded
she walked in here and Jim and I just
completely just you talked about it yo
yes you so Popeye yes what a baby she
was the one went on baby she went on the
view and she called us beavis and
butt-head oh yeah
the best all bullies no matter what they
can't take being bullied right and you
weren't even bullying you were just
asking for some facts like let me call
you on your [ __ ] yeah right resort yeah
where you was you're both like I was
like wow these guys are really doing
this nicely but you know you know she
knew right away oh my god they're doing
to be what I do to people for a real
griller of interviews she [ __ ]
collapse fast like she was look like she
was willing to fight like she's
definitely ferocious but then she just
ends the interview and lasers right at
me doing yeah you're on TV so you can't
exactly when you're on her show you
can't that's that's what I'm thinking
right I'm I'm thinking if I get up and
walk away I'm going to embarrass the
business right because it makes it look
like you are on drugs and won't tell
anybody about it right you can't
I'm just breathe he did say and I
remember talking about cuz and I said it
then I've said it numerous times WWE has
the the highest standard of policy like
for drugs and everything like cuz if so
many guys have going down
you know over the years there they have
the strictest policy way stricter than
the NFL right or the MLB like way
stricter you had some you had some
painkiller in you somewhere
you better have like the exact reasons a
doctor everything and they're just the
guys today they don't do pills right my
day everybody did you know and you know
again today these guys are they're not
out partying all night long let's say to
no party but not like we did you know
they're playing video games or on
computers and you know it's just a
different generation you know yeah yeah
yeah I'm happy for them because there's
a whole lot of amazing athletes out
there so she ambushed you basically nice
yeah again I get what's so dice before
Jim so what do you what'd he do after
the show like what you do once once the
segment's over and she goes well thank
you Dallas for joining us I you know I I
don't remember what I said but I know I
said something in a way of like go [ __ ]
yourself but I didn't say that
right I said it very close which
language this is my house I just who
knowing the Internet yeah I knew the
fallout what was about to come right you
remember I went did your show oh yeah
right after that you didn't you dropped
you drop the see bomb on her what you
say yo you know this hahaha he goes like
that and he was like he's like I don't
even want to talk about because I
remember you're like saying I'll talk to
you about it but I'm not talking to
anybody else about it after this dude
and at you guys just and I didn't see it
coming but Dallas likes to be and he
goes Sam I'll tell you Nancy she she was
a Content yeah I was so I was so mad
because again the fallout that came on
the internet and I was more worried and
concerned with the family forget me you
know forget it I didn't want them right
to feel that right and I was sorry I saw
I saw his wife and his kids a training
out there is the nicest people man you
know I'm always I always make sure to
come the other company brings me in for
you know for some signings and stuff
everybody so mania cuz it's such a
spectacle I love going I love go
the hall-of-fame I love going to the
different events and stuff I haven't
been to the NXT shows but they sure I'm
going because I you know there's they've
just I mean Triple H's really built that
whole NXT brand yeah that's his baby you
know and these kids that they got what I
love and this is what was a part of our
generation especially with the whole NWO
and the more and us kicking at one time
kicking WWE's s yeah I love the fan
interaction like I used to love to watch
ECW because of the fan so even when you
were wrestling you were watching other
wrestling everything everything I'll
tell you story about Ripley's I've told
us before because I watched everything
huh when I first came up with the
diamond cutter it was given to me by
Johnny Ace and he did it with one arm so
I had to change it and do it tune and do
it as a hold called the cravat
what is the diamond cut I don't know
what that is the diamond cutters were I
would get a guy's head like right here
and then I just kick out now you can go
with me and we can dance together or you
could try not to go or hesitate you're
still going right and I would as I say
so if there's resistance you're hitting
your neck broken there's any yeah yeah
so Triple H was there that day when
Johnny gave that to me and then I
started to take out of nowhere and
people want to be surprised and my
finish even if you're not a wrestling
fan because it came out of nowhere the
crowd would pop right and but Triple H
was there today and one day cuz i watch
everything he I see he did it to
somebody he had his own finish the
pedigree which is amazing but one day
cuz he's so eg does so many different
moves and stuff and understands the
psychology biz he called it a diamond
cutter out of nowhere I was like oh no
not him because he's the only guy who
had like my work ethic yeah he's like
he's got even sicker work ethic than I
do and I called him up and he answered
the phone I was like hey Paulie you know
I hey dally what you doing it's a guy I
got a favor to ask you sure when you
want
I said no don't say yes yet yeah don't
say yes yet
that uh because I have no right to ask
you because you wanted two different
Federation's each one could have the
same move sting had to go to Scorpion
Deathlock and sharpshooter Sharpton yeah
yeah sharpshooter and I wrestled I did
the chop like chief Jay Strongbow you
didn't do the claw no that is just a
shock the trot was at your finisher it
certainly was a weak finisher if you
think I went down that's all about it
with I guess so so of course you were
bigger than right I was much bigger yes
we used to do a lot of Bob Backlund knee
walking I did you know that that's lower
leg strength only on dates though they
tell they say you don't want you got you
got that great finish you know and
really I
you got uh uh all I got is this move
this is like what I got it's like it's
exploding my career it's on the rise and
you know and I really wish you would do
it again anyway
sure date and never why don't we get so
you were like - dude this is the only
move I got don't so my mode but I did it
like I figured it out I made it a thing
but now it's like it's it's kind of a
you know RKO out of nowhere right is the
big thing and you just hit the diamond
cutter out of nowhere it's pretty yeah
pretty similar
how do people not [ __ ] in a neck up
though and they landed on the on the
ground with you like that like with your
arm under their neck um hopefully they
kick out and a goat and they dance with
me you know it's like one of those
things yo the thing I mean I actually
called Randy he didn't remember me doing
it cuz he just got out of the hospital
with shoulder surgery but I called him
it I wanted Randy to do it cuz I love
his Randy Orton yeah yeah I love his
work in the ring and I died back then he
was very young back then when I call it
was 22 or 23 at the time and I love that
he does it and he's found new ways that
I would thought wow that's amazing how
do you keep coming up with new ways and
I had I had 50 different ways into it
now there's probably like 120 yeah yeah
when did they start liking you at WWE
because the thing was DDP was WCW guy
and like like you said WCW was kicking
WWE's ass for a little bit and because
of that there was a lot of tension you
know business business almost went under
and that's this whole livelihood in life
but it seems like you're not treated
like a WCW you were brought in and now
they're doing documentaries and now
they're doing like they have you hosting
other DVDs all started it all started
with that because they wanted me to be a
color commentator at the end because I'm
probably really good at that especially
towards the end and you have to be in it
I'm not I couldn't go back and do what I
did 12 years ago it's color commentator
because I'm not around it all the time a
repetition share of learning but back
then I was pretty good at it and they
asked me to do it and I just needed to
get away I needed to get away from
wrestling and when I went when I went
away I went away away because no one
called me nothing and then about I guess
about six years ago I got a phone call
and they wanted me to do the very best
of nitro and the original script that I
read I didn't call Mac and they called
me and he said so yo did you get the
script I was like yeah we said so what
do you think I said I think you don't
want me to do this and they were like no
no we really want you to do this and I
said well I'm like you know I'm not
gonna say some of the things that you
say I get that history was written by
the winners I mean I get that more than
anybody gotcha right so there was some
things that were skewed certain ways so
they're making it seem like you know
nitro was always this kind of little
show over here DDP is there as opposed
to something that actually beat them for
a while right I said you you saw when we
beat your ass for 89 weeks right even
you saw that like we trampled you I said
so there's certain things I'm not going
to say he goes so change him and I was
like really okay and then I learned it
from bell-to-bell me the buddy my name
Matt who's really great kid and really
understood the business and I wanted
what the fans wanted to hear so Matt and
I actually wrote my dialogue together
and we did it for all three best of
nitros and really really sharp kid
really sharp kid then came you know the
the the show ups of legends I'd be up on
legends for once in a while sure and
then they brought me
for the was the next thing it was really
big oh yeah the thousands episode yeah
he showed up on your video screen Rose
hitting Heath Slater who's all over
their TV right down yeah he's a hell of
a talent I'm so happy that he's getting
the opportunity because that's what it's
all about
he put a lot of time and now he's
getting the opportunity but he took a
beautiful diamond cutter for me and the
crowd Wow
you know next thing I know I'm back
there for old school raw and Triple H
gives me just gives me a little
infomercial in the back you know he's
like do that thing where you pull your
foot over your head yo it's a they let
him do like they let DDP show you know
how Vince likes to advertise his own
stuff you know they let DDP show up and
do a whole promo with his DDP yoga
t-shirt on doing yoga like basically
just selling it was like that and Shark
Tank I feel like major millionaire I'll
tell you what happened but not only that
but also Jake showed up that night and
no one had seen Jake on TV for 16 years
cuz he was like banished yeah you know
because such your drugs I'm sure all
that you know he was a bad example but
now he was turning around so this is a
big deal that day I are it blew our
internet up the for DDP yoga calm it
blew us up so much it shut my site down
so when we did Shark Tank we brought on
27 servers so if one server started shut
down and go to the next server let's
start to get shut down go to the next
sir we did a million dollars in sales in
six days in six days it was that strong
but back to WWE then they brought me in
for the BD I'm thinking well of course
I'm gonna induct Jake and then I
realized when they called me to to
induct him oh wait a minute this is
their TV that does it be happy oh just
because Jake would have wanted me to do
it doesn't know they still get to make
the call third TV yeah yeah so they
asked me to do that which was huge I got
to induct Jake and Scott went and on my
58th birthday which was it was really
really cool and then to come back I
never thought I'd ever be in a run
again and then being a rumble and get
three different diamond cutters for the
top guys yeah over the top and then the
wrestle at WrestleMania I mean I just
walked up to Stephanie Hunter game a big
huggers and thank you so much for the
birthday present and I would have done
it for nothing right right because what
yet to be 60 you know and you up didn't
go out do that the only other guy knows
done that that age is Ric Flair to be a
net breath a Ric Flair at any moment you
know in our business now that many
people don't want Ric Flair's then I
would say no one's done what Ric Flair's
Diamond so to be you know he's the he
did it in the sixties and probably to do
it that's pretty cool you know we got to
get you out of here but before you go
Joe and main wants to say something real
quick what's going on Joe diamond you
helped save my life um the rehab a
couple months ago almost have a liver
failure and then got out and then
started doing TV yoga I'm down 70 pounds
Wow Wow and the Jake interview helped me
so much that documentary did so I
appreciated it well thank you say that
man I'm glad to hear you're on the right
track that's awesome thanks Joe if you
have like a co-host DDP who's got like
an annoying little ponch in his belly
that he stares at sometimes during
interviews and gets disgusted at is that
something you think DDP yoga can take
care of was it possible it DDP yoga is
never set up as a weight-loss program uh
but I've had people lose literally
hundreds of pounds because that is how I
get your heart rate jacked up yeah I
always say that most Yogi's are very
namaste DDP yoga way more ta okay a lot
of tone and attitude is oh it's a
workout we have heartrate jacked up here
it's more of a cardio thing to me to do
anything and also breaks up scar tissue
so you know get you more flexible makes
you stronger it's why I can do what I
can do at sixty years old and one thing
I do want to leave you with here yes did
you get a chance to see the DDP video
wake up alarm clock I saw it but Samm
refused I haven't seen it yet but I've
heard about it dude I'll tell you what
right now we've got
ten alarms up there and a lot of them
are you know inspirational but there's
some ones that are really funny there's
ones that are they're ridiculous it also
says Jake Roberts DDP tap dancing oh my
god and is this on any anyway if you've
got iPhone you're good iTunes you get
good on app stores and stuff it's
everywhere and it's a free app all right
we'll check it out and when you do get
it make sure that you set it for AM AM
NOT yeah yeah you can go to DDP yoga
calm you can follow DDP at real DDP uh I
hope this one better than the Nancy
Grace interview did one last thing I
can't believe I forgot it DDP yoga now
is now an app and it's guys everywhere
and it's got everything in it from
inspirational to food cooking shows lot
it today's motivational Monday and I'm
out of here right here but motivational
Monday I talk up with Jake I interviewed
Jake where he is today and for anybody
once seen it's a there's a free app on
DDP yoga now and there is a subscription
but the free part has all the
inspirational stuff and has that
interview guys so check it out Sam oh
great singing again buddy thank you
buddy
thank you Jim